good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy home day it is
wednesday here at the morning toast and
you know what that means we're getting
frisky we're humping some boys that we
love yes if you're watching on youtube
you are
seeing it's not a mirage it really is
bryson thrice in the flesh in the flesh
we have these little cute dog pillows
and they are so lifelike and i just
can't get over it they spark so much joy
if you're looking for a gift for someone
like this is the gift that keeps on
giving every day walk into the studio
and i have a smile on my face because
the image of bryce is among us 100
um happy wednesday jax hey nerd i'm
doing good we should actually bring
bryce and dyson here they've never been
here together like we should do a
chaotic episode a chaotic episode with
them boys we're due for a chaotic
episode maybe like at the end of a long
week when there's like not much to talk
about maybe you're hungover like that's
the vibe i mean i'm so down i guess i i
could have a drink for the sake of our
work for the sake of this show yeah
i'm doing good we have such a busy day
today we had a very busy day yesterday
we recorded an interview with austin
kroll let's talk about it and we need to
talk about jackie wants to give this our
culture a stern talking to you i need to
give the comments on our instagram post
to stern talking to so before you do
that let's just say austin's interview
was on our podcast today but if you're a
youtube subscriber you caught it early
yesterday so a lot of people have seen
the interview already if you haven't and
you're listening as a podcast feel free
to just continue listening and if you
have um you want to watch it it's up on
our youtube channel when we announced it
on our instagram yesterday the comments
were ablaze like we were everyone's like
no no like we were literally having like
casey anthony on our show like
like so disappointed like what who i'm
like dude austin murder someone like i
didn't know that you would think that he
did it's so crazy so first of all the
interview was really enjoyable and this
was our first time having him on the
show and i just really enjoyed our
conversation and we talked a lot about
you know what happened on summer house
and the more that we talked about it i
was like
this is a tv show right this man like
had a bad weekend he acted a fool
disrespectfully sure but like
not the biggest steal ever and like the
comments you guys like hopefully you're
just like saying it and like not really
having
like you don't actually feel you don't
have too much like invested in the
situation like if you do like put your
phone down go outside take a walk it's
not good for your mental health and
honestly it was really shocking to see
and i think that's why like austin took
the interview really seriously like just
chill like okay you were a little rude
to sierra but you did apologize and it's
like you didn't kill sierra like
you just made out with your friend like
i was like what what are we missing i
was shook at the backlash and that's how
you know like backlash culture has
gotten so out of control so out of
control so i think as a group like we
just need to zoom out of the situation
and
take a breath just relax and watch the
interview because it's really great and
claudia and i spoke after the show we
were facetiming and we have to say like
he is not the honda civic male
attractiveness he is a range rover he is
so handsome
so tall smells
so good has i'm sorry like you just
don't get to where you get
by being a honda civic like he is that
like he is what people think like he is
yeah he is he has that presence about
him he has that like star quality gina
sequoia yeah so it was nice to you know
suss it out for ourselves and evaluate
and yeah we decided that he is a ranger
he's a range rover for sure so everyone
just calm down watch the interview it's
good we also got like good southern
charm tea we were talking about you know
the patricia of it all so there's a lot
of good stuff in there again if you're
listening as a podcast just keep
listening and if you want to watch it as
a video head over to our youtube channel
and please like [ __ ] subscribe okay
claudia's really trying to get
subscribers these days because when you
get a hundred thousand subscribers you
get that youtube plaque you guys
subscribe and i want it and we're at 80
and we've i agree because people just
tune in they don't subscribe because
we're not like one of those channels
where it's like click baity like we just
start consistently and it's like you
know you'll get a video every day so
like you don't need to just subscribe
and like get alerted get alerted whereas
other people like when are they gonna
drop their videos who knows so seriously
can you guys just [ __ ] subscribe
ready so we can get our plaques and also
um do we get two plaques like we better
like not just get one we better but if
we only get one i'll let you keep no
we'll have it in the studio yeah we'll
put it right there also if you listen as
a podcast just go subscribe i know
everyone has a youtube account because
it's like connected to your email so
like they won't bother you just
subscribe even if you don't watch it on
youtube yeah that's why i've been like
so annoying about it okay now it makes
sense i want a plaque now it makes sense
because in the caption you wrote
yesterday you were being like so like
not so click here to subscribe subscribe
how do we add one of those buttons click
here yeah
to subscribe ding ding ding uh and now
it makes sense so thank you for
enlightening do you think i'm getting a
backlash for that nazi thing i just said
well you never know austin got i would
say no but after the comments it's true
but i'm jewish but i feel like i can
really say whatever i want
in that department in some regards yes
um so we've got a great show for you
guys today it's wednesday which of
course means dear toasters so i also
just wanted to say something um we were
going through the emails this morning
of um like dear toaster submissions and
you would be surprised how many people
write in and then write a follow-up like
please don't read this i changed my mind
oh wow so i just want to let you guys
know we do see your follow-up emails and
we will not read something that you have
redacted some cold-footed queens yes um
it's typically more about like serious
topics than like you know my bridesmaid
is annoying me so i get it but i just
wanted to put ever i feel like there's
people like who tune in every wednesdays
being like please don't read mine please
don't read mine and if you write us
redacting we will redact okay very
interesting i had no idea yeah okay also
we need to recapitalize of new jersey
the third and final part of the reunion
was last night the most heated part
lots to do really good really good i
very much enjoyed it and i have many
thoughts so we will do all that
with some mediocre stories as we always
do i'm feeling good about the stories
there's a lot of different ways we can
take them which is all i'm looking for
with stories they are you know a loose
framework for us just talking about
ourselves it's a good news kind of day
it is a good news good interesting new
sort of day nothing pressing nothing
kardashian everyone like calm down you
can take a breath
i don't even want to go down this road
just like everyone talking about how we
talk about them too much like i'm sorry
if courtney gets married we have to talk
about it can you tell the cover of si we
have to talk about 100
100
100
and i guess we could get into everything
because we have tons to do i guess
i don't know you seem rdh no i don't
know i'm just like what else do i want
to talk about before i am forced to talk
about other people you know yeah
um i had such a crazy dream last night
that like really shook the foundation of
my life you know i'm not going to share
it i had a crazy dream last night too
but you know it's bottom of the barrel
conversation topics when we're talking
about our dreams no and sometimes dreams
are like extremely telling of like
something you're going through so we
really shouldn't be sharing our dreams
because someone could read into our
subconscious and be like hmm now i know
what she's all about right 100 that's
what i said because i was reading a book
or two on like
therapy like good morning monster and
the therapist like wants to know what
the patient's dreams are so she can
understand what they're actually
thinking and feeling and it's like oh
[ __ ] i'm never telling you guys my
dreams again even though i never did
before because i think it's boring as
[ __ ] do you have any recurring dreams
like for over the years no not recurring
dreams but like recurring things that
happen themes yeah me too like i'm in a
car in the brakes don't work oh i'm
trying to run and my legs are slow oh
okay we're giving away too much of
ourselves i have um like i'm trying to
like fight someone and like i i
physically can't land a punch
also like this also of course like
screaming and nothing comes out oh i
don't really have that much one so much
and then also i've told ben about this
like for years like ever since i was a
kid i've had like a dream every couple
of years
about this like i don't even know what
it is it's like a hotel it's like a
theater it's like this rose gold it's
like this beautiful place and like i'll
see it in my dreams like once every five
or ten years literally so interesting
and like all i want to do is get back
there because it's like this gorgeous
place and
for some reason there's like a childhood
associate there's like an element of
nostalgia there i can't figure out i
can't put my finger in the dream like
where i am but it's like a place i've
known forever i honestly like i feel
like
honestly i sometimes think i'm like
clairvoyant and i think that like i'm
entering heaven like i'm sleeping so
deep i might die
then that's clairvoyant how um because
i'm being shown the afterlife oh
yeah and it's glorious it's stunning
that's why i have to behave here on
earth so i can get there that's really i
think that's maybe like
god's way of like keeping me on track
like showing me a little bit of what i
could get if i continue to be a good
person okay so let's be good people
today i'll try it'll be easy with these
stories no problems nothing crazy yeah
today will be easy so without further
ado without further talk about our
fascinating dreams it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
pros after jackie had her baby of course
she started to notice a lot of her hair
shedding and she was concerned were you
not no it's so it starts at month three
which i've officially entered and there
is more shedding there's more in the
drain there's more in the bed there's
more at the edge of my ponytail so after
pregnancy your body is still shifting
and recalibrating and one of the
alarming side effects of that is
excessive shedding so that's hair that
comes out in clumps even when you wash
it or brush brush it but thankfully
jackie found pros to help stop the
shedding cycle and grow her hair back
pro specializes in custom hair care and
now they also make custom hair
supplements that are personally tailored
to address your specific cause of
shedding so they take into account
things like hormonal changes stress
level diet and more and the result is
customized supplements guaranteed to
help you grow thicker longer softer hair
in record time they're made with clean
safe and natural ingredients pros hair
supplements are just two capsules you
take daily in fact multiple studies show
that over 90 of women taking pros hair
supplements saw less shedding more
growth and improved overall appearance
in just 90 days try your own custom hair
supplements and you'll get 15 percent
off
get yours at pros.com toast that's
p-r-o-s-e
dot com
toast for your free in-depth hair
consultation and 15 off custom hair
supplements today's episode is also
brought to you
by modern fertility we're supposed to go
to the ob gyn once a year for our annual
checkups but checking in with our
fertility isn't usually a thing that
we're doing unless we're ready for kids
and that's why modern fertility was
created an easy and affordable way to
test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get
personalized results within 10 days
you'll get insight into your hormone
levels your ovarian reserve aka how many
eggs you have compared to other women
your age and other important fertility
factors the results go deep into what
every hormone means and you can also
talk one on one with a fertility nurse
to review your results and options for
next steps traditional testing with your
doctor can cost over a thousand dollars
but modern fertility gets you the same
information at 159
which is a fraction of the cost and if
you go to modernfertility.com toast you
can get 20 off your test so that's 139
instead of 159 or instead of over a
thousand dollars at the doctor's office
that's modernfertility.com toast modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test at
modernfertility.com toast 20 off your
fertility test modernfertility.com
toast what a good bundle of ads i know
that's what we call vertical integration
vertical integration use modern
fertility get pregnant lose your hairs
get pros
we're covering all stages of life here
at the morning toast we really are are
you ready for our first story some
good charity news finally evan spiegel
and miranda kerr pay off student loans
for otis college's graduating class evan
spiegel the co-founder of snapchat and
his wife miranda kerr the model and
entrepreneur are paying off the student
loans for otis college of art and
designs 2022 graduating class they said
we know that for most of you and your
families the shared burden of student
debt is a heavy price that you pay for
an exceptional otis education
i'm sorry that's what the president of
the school said
we understand that this debt can
compromise your future and limit your
creative ambitions we do not want to see
this happen he goes on to announce that
the school was given the largest gift in
the history of otis college through the
spiegel family fund their gift will
enable you to repay your student loans
he said which was met with cheers and a
standing ovation oh my god the kids were
quaking if you haven't seen the video
it's the cutest thing um the kids at the
graduation ceremony like had no idea
that this was coming so it was like
sprung on them and they were like
screaming they were all like looking
around like is this real that's so
awesome so evan and miranda they weren't
like the keynote speakers or anything i
don't know i they were just
they were there i don't know what their
position was but they were there for
whatever reason maybe evan spoke he
attended a high school program at otis
college when he was 15 years old oh how
cute and he said that the program was
tough and it made him a better designer
oh my god i love this story for a
million reasons one one of my favorite
like celebrity fairy tale endings is
that of miranda kerr like so random um
but i love it like she just she had such
a
sickening career as a model and then
like one day just
had a fairy tale happy ending like
businessman bo like what literally
what's better than that businessman bo
and he is one of the more handsome
billionaires
extremely handsome like beyond and like
got successful really young so like has
always been like really rich and young
and handsome yeah um so i love that
journey for her and i love this concept
like of course so many celebrities do
charity but i think there's like a
special
like paying off student loans is like a
special type of charity because it's
like you're literally like cleaning
someone's slate for their future that's
like
just like the night it's like such a
nice financial gift but also like the
emotional
baggage that comes with student loans
like you're just like wiping that slate
clean for people and it's so nice yeah
and plenty of celebrities billionaires
do donate to charity but it's hard when
you donate to an organization say like
it's hard to see the immediate impact on
like individual people
and
it's awesome to just see like these kids
they're immediately affected and their
you know current status of their lives
are changing how much do you think it
was
i thought you said it was oh no i don't
know they just said it was the largest
sum they're you know they're so classy
they didn't say how much but like let's
guess can you google how many how many
students graduated okay from otis
and then they said 90 of the students
carry student loans otis graduating
class
size
it's like a small school i believe so
otis said it has a total undergraduate
enrollment of 1030. so divide that by
four
oh
so it's still nice it's still like 250
and then ninety percent of 250 which is
what like let me go to 230 calculator
app
225.
so then what do you think the average
student loan payment is like 10 000
maybe more well let's go to tuition well
and it compounds like over the years
that's why people end up with so much
more debt because it literally sets you
up
for financial failure
it's four it's fifty thousand dollars to
go to otis yeah but if you're on
financial aid or you have a loan like
it might not be for the whole tuition
all right let's just say for argument's
sake fifty thousand times what no it's
definitely not for the whole tuition
right times 235
how much did i say 225. no but at 50 000
that's one year
oh my gosh calculator is like thirsty oh
this is
this is adding up it's
200 000
times 225 225.
45 million
but that's at assuming everybody had a
hundred percent tuition right
wow wow i don't think they donated that
much no
when we were first doing the math i was
like so they donated
twenty thousand dollars
let's call it 20 mil that is so generous
and it's like obviously i said this
already but like it's so generous
money-wise but also like what they're
doing for this generation it's just like
it's amazing i love i love these two
like they're one of my favorite low-key
celebrity couples and now like and in
the video like when the kids start
screaming they cut to miranda and evan
they just like look at each other and
smile it is the cutest thing and this is
just a good news story all around i love
i stan some good news to kick off the
day i think that's what we all needed
you know
now are you ready for our next story
which is some funny news sure cardi b is
showing how she changes diapers with her
claw like nails such a good question i
of course have wondered okay so she made
a video of her changing a diaper on a
teddy bear she said okay girl so i just
made a whole video trust me you will get
the hang of it however i do feel like
boys are harder to clean they got more
crevices
[Laughter]
100 they definitely have more crevices
but it's really crazy that she's
changing diapers with these nails
because even my nails like right um
this all started like in the last few
weeks like the hair loss and the nails
the nails they were so strong and so i
didn't want to cut them because they
were so long i've never had such long
nails in my life but i'm also trying to
change diapers and there's like you know
decitin
under my nails i recently did get a
spatula a diaper spatula which like
seems like one of those nonsense tools
so the spatula you put the cream on and
then you put the cream on the tushy yeah
so your fingers like don't
interact and it is very useful it's not
like some
useless thing well i think people
probably assume that cardi b didn't even
change diapers because she's like so
rich she had someone doing it for her so
i love that she's just like still one of
us yeah um
and there are these girls on tick tock
who have like crazy long nails and they
make videos like here's how i put in
chapstick here is how i open a can and
so there is like these focta ways of
doing things when you have really long
nails i just don't know why you would
make your life harder like life is so
hard life is so hard and having short
trim nails just how do you type on your
phone how do you pick your nose even
when my nails are really long actually i
feel like you it depends on the nail
length no if you have like a nice little
like
centimeter tip it's really good for
scooping out boogers for sure but i'm
talking about like acrylics like
seriously how do you think about your
food really hurt yourself of course you
could cause a nosebleed yeah a sinus
infection and when you have so much like
when you have really long nails there's
so much surface area for your under nail
and then it likes gets like smelly yeah
i'm watching this video of her doing the
diaper and she really has great
technique she's so funny she's like one
of my favorite celebs and she's always
always keeping it real so even in
motherhood she's just a regular girl a
regular girl but still
those nails take a break no no i agree
especially like okay
i feel like she has been doing somebody
used to have those nails yeah but i
don't have a child but you used to have
like
long ass i used to do acrylics probably
like half an inch yeah olivia too
remember olivia used to do like the
claws yeah it's really fun and by the
way it makes your hand look so like sexy
and skinny and you could talk with
attitude it's a little annoying for like
remedial things but if you don't have a
child like it's not
it's not
to the point where like you can't wipe
your ass those types of acrylics but
really really long ones that are like
two inches long maybe longer like you
like literally how do you wipe your ass
i don't know
that's good this girl and tick tock
showed how she wiped her ass like she
was obviously using like a s synthetic
ass she was using she was wearing like
biker shorts oh cute and it's just like
you could do it but it's just harder so
i just i can't understand making life
harder because i already have such
trouble you know just getting out of bed
agreed
agreed and i think cardi b sometimes
wears ones with like charms
so that's just like an added layer like
girl
it's okay i feel like she hasn't been
doing a lot of public appearances like
you can take your nails off like when
you're in the comfort of your own home
yeah my nails are shorties right now and
i don't even want to talk about my nails
let me see
why do you have such like nail problems
problems oh because your local place
closed my local nail salon closed and
even when it was open like i find
getting a manicure to be the most
like exhausting task like i don't find
it enjoyable i don't it's not like a
thing where i like treat myself like
it's not luxurious i find it just to be
like exhausting and so like tedious so i
don't go and so then i'll get a gel
manicure like every couple of months
because i'm literally so lazy and then
the gel will like grow out and i'll peel
it off which ruins the quality of your
nails and then i have an event or a show
or something a trip so i put on my
press-ons which is so bad for your nails
so i'm in this like disgusting cycle
where i just can't get healthy clean
beautiful nails so right now like i
don't even want to show you they're
disgusting
well i used to feel that way about
getting manicures too like it's a chore
but now it's like an hour of
the day of the week that's like just for
me to pamper myself and now i see it
differently so maybe you should have a
baby and then you'll enjoy getting
manicures again okay you just can't use
that for everything jackie like just
every time you complain about like
something in your life i'm like having a
child or being pregnant would solve this
for you
and it would help your nails grow but
think about all the other problems i
would have if i was pregnant yeah yeah
yeah all the other heartburn
heartburn the heartburn for me
was and do you have heartburn like as a
normie no i do but here's the thing oh
and i meant to mention this when we did
our um
what's birth story episode i don't know
if i ever did i had heart really bad
heartburn throughout my pregnancy and at
the end specifically and i had horrible
heartburn while i was pushing but you
can't take like a time uh i could but i
thought it was like i thought that since
the baby was like moving down like it
was gonna i just didn't evaluate it and
so i wish i brought tom's oh i did tell
the story because i had to take some
anta that was but you were disgusting i
was gonna say you're literally in a
hospital just actually gave me something
it was
lighter fluid it was what was it like
chewable no a drink
ew it was awful and then i did have a
little bit of heartburn for like one to
two days after but now i'm like back to
how i was before which is heartburn it's
not something that i suffer from oh my
god i'm telling you i don't know if
heartburn is contagious but i only
started getting it when i met ben
because like i'll never forget i was in
ben's car which is like his family car
and they're just like a a heartburn
family so ben's open opens up the middle
console to this
tub of tums and i'm like what i'm like
i've seen commercials for times i'm like
i had no idea i'm like what is that he's
like for heartburn he's like you want
one i'm like no he's like try it they're
actually like they're like smoothie
flavored i'm like okay and i'm telling
you i just like took a tom randomly that
gave me heartburn for the rest of my
life activated now i'm like thank god
for ben's family whenever we're in the
car mark where is the tub of toms
but they also started this for you no i
know
vicious cycle vicious cycle but like i
really get it bad when i'm hungover
because i pretty much exclusively drink
margaritas which are really acidic and
cause heartburn makes sense yeah so
that's your little fun fact about me are
you ready for our next story sure story
story carmen electro is joining only
fans carmen electra has launched her
only fans account the former baywatch
babe will provide members with exclusive
access to fun edgy and playful content
the 96 symbol was inspired to reconnect
with her fan base after she turned 50 in
april and is looking forward to this new
celebratory chapter of her life
ahead of the uh release she released a
steamy photo of herself lying in bed and
teased wednesday i have a huge
announcement only for my fans are you a
fan
cause it's only fans
what's wrong oh i'm just looking for a
[ __ ] to give like
i literally don't [ __ ] care like it's
crazy i was like when you were saying
the story i'm like let's think of
something funny to say i'm like no you
know what i literally don't care
sorry
savage plus i ran the stories by you no
i know and like i guess it is
interesting like because this is like
the new age of sex symbolism and she was
like that [ __ ] and now she's continuing
and i get it it's like the old and the
new don't care okay
you know like i agree
i i do agree
i probably like i can't even think of
something funny to say like i probably
wouldn't have been sorry
but sure yeah i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i
literally don't give a flying [ __ ] do
you think she'll have success like do
you think all of the old like people who
used to have her poster on her wall are
like gonna be i don't know because like
those people are now like you know
husbands like i don't know i really i
have no idea if this is gonna be a
success i'm not gonna be a flop but like
i don't think she's gonna be breaking
records because like it's just a really
weird platform like the people who make
so much money are people you've never
heard of bad baby behind bahabi right
yeah like the top creators on there like
you've literally never heard their names
before yeah
okay
so like love we love women in business
we do but like i just
i don't care okay i think that's really
fair yeah it's a fair assessment of this
story yeah and we can move on to the
next one which i really care about okay
which is that the yellowstone prequel
1932 has cast helen mirren and harrison
ford so we spoke about a while ago how
1883 was not getting renewed for a
second season that's because it was like
a one-time show and now the next show is
1932. so we're still following the
dutton family throughout history but now
we're going straight to 1932 and
harrison ford and helen mirren will star
as the new generation of dutton's
thoughts
um i don't really have any since i don't
watch the show you don't watch
yellowstone no i know and it's gonna be
one of those things in like five years i
am not listening and you're not
and you're not allowed to recap on this
i will watch it and be like jackie you
were so right like i would take down
tonight yeah how i did with the kindle i
know claudia i know it's in my future
i'm just not there yet okay but i'm just
letting you know like because you won't
listen to me right now like you're not
allowed to like recap it in the tv recap
like you have to keep it to yourself no
we're gonna watch this in like five
years
oh five years for me i hope you're doing
well hope you're taking care of that
rash and i love you five years for me
like hope you're doing great hope you've
lost some of this weight and that your
hair comes back
totally no the hair loss is like just
starting like i don't even know how bad
it's going to get
no i know like i kind of feel like a
bald moment for you would be sickening
well if it does get really bad i will
also just cut it shorter to make it
healthier yeah yeah that's my answer for
everything just cut your hair totally
feeling low cut your hair no don't
actually basic cut your hair looking
basic cut your hair for sure yeah um
what are my thoughts on this what was
the year 1932. you know i feel like we
spoke about this with downton abbey like
when we do like old-timey pieces
whenever we get to like the 1930s i'm
like
i can only think about the holocaust you
know yeah oh yeah you measure like
history in terms of that's how i
personally measure [ __ ] so like in
downton abbey what are we up to like
1921 1927 was the first movie so we
probably won't get there but i'm always
saying like england was like you know in
europe so i'm always thinking about that
so um
1932 is like great depression in america
right and dust bowl for the midwest
which [ __ ] is dust bowl uh
like
i read this book the four winds which is
about it but it's like in the midwest
there was like all of these different
like agricultural and environmental
circumstances that made it so there was
like a horrible drought and the whole
like planes were incredibly dusty and
they would get these hard like they
couldn't they wasn't growing crops it
was like famine and the land was barren
and there were these horrible dust
storms and why doesn't that happen
anymore um because first of all they
were over farming the land
and really like abusing it and so it
wasn't regenerating plus there was this
combination of drought and now there are
better like farming practices so that we
don't you know
got it and i guess like where some of
those like dusty planes were like now
there's like buildings on right
perhaps i mean i'm sure it could get
dusty again but it was just there was so
much prosperous it was like and it was
also at the time of depression so there
was like
no reason resources
etc so do you think 1933 will cover the
dust bowl i think it should because i do
believe they're in montana so this would
make harrison ford like uh
kevin costner's what like great
grandfather
uh
if kevin costner was like born in the
50s this would be his father then right
20 or no no no maybe grandfather yeah
yeah yeah his grandfather probably hot
family yeah i love harrison ford i love
harrison ford obviously not for the
reasons i need my son after him
literally not for the reasons one might
think like never seen indiana jones but
i have seen indiana joni
um but i'm much more i'm interested in
harrison's late work like morning glory
yeah agreed no when i was thinking about
naming my son harrison like harrison
ford being himself was it definitely a
motivating factor a pro a pro
always compare like when you're thinking
of babies like to the most famous person
with that name you know yeah and when i
would see his name i'm like okay this
sparks joy
yeah totally and helen mirren always a
queen queen yeah
but like these are some those are two
really big names no for tv like remember
back in the day like and for like
paramount yeah but it's like literally
the most watched show on tv it's the
most watched show on tv but i just
remember the times where like being on
tv was like embarrassing if you were
like a movie star and once you made it
to the movies you would never go back to
the small screen and now it's like
there's more money in television tv is
just better than movies these days and
more people are watching tv than are
watching movies so if you actually want
to be famous like get in the tv show
queens gambit
yeah i miss queen's gambit i know that
was like we haven't had a show
like that in so long i know you know
what i'm i'm waiting um
up next on my content plate but like i
don't want to watch what i'm like
feeling flick clamped like i want to
watch on like a rainy sunday you know
conversations with friends
which is like
normal people right yeah yeah i'm i'm
gonna watch out because joe alwyn is in
it it didn't like normal people the show
i didn't like normal people the book i
didn't read the book i like normal
people
i don't like sally rooney the author i
won't be watching conversations with
friends oh wow okay that's my thought
she's doing a stance i'm taking a stance
you know girl live your life
um
and speaking of names that spark joy are
you ready for our fifth and final story
which is the popular most popular baby
names of 2022 for boys and girls i am
and it's brought to you by pear eyewear
which is just a crazy coincidence to
your grade
change up your look in a snap pair
eyewear's base frame and magnetic top
frame combination makes it easy to
switch up your style they have base
frames that start at just 60 dollars
including prescription lenses there are
hundreds of top frame designs to match
whichever base frames you choose and
they also do a pair for repair so for
every pair purchased pair provides
glasses and vision care for children
around the world you are a unique mashup
of all your favorite things and there's
a multitude of ways to express yourself
so celebrate all that you are and
explore who you can be with customizable
prescription glasses from pear eyewear
so if you wear glasses a lot like it can
be kind of monotonous like what if
you're wearing gingham look you know
what if you're wearing houndstooth what
if you're wearing um
plaid thank you
it's just not fair that you should be
you know chained to this one pair of
glasses so true so pear is the
affordable way to switch up your eye
look and like just constantly be
evolving and glasses are in right now
like sexy school teacher yes so pair
eyewear is great you get the base frame
and then you get these different little
toppers to just change up every time
you're wearing your gingham getup
so um and they also do a pair for a pair
which i already mentioned so they're
providing glasses and vision care for
children around the world get glasses
that are unique
get glasses that are as unique as you
are they have one pair but infinite
styles starting at just sixty dollars go
to pair eyewear dot com slash toast for
fifteen percent off your first purchase
that's fifteen percent off at p a i r i
wear dot com slash toast for fifteen
percent off great thank you now our
fifth and final story social security
administration annually tracks the names
given to boys and girls in each state
what we're talking about social security
since the year 1880 and now the data for
the top baby names for boys and girls
has emerged and and the proof is that we
are influential queens the headline here
is that the name theodore has entered
the top 10 names for boys for the first
time i wonder why
i'm shocked i wonder why okay are you
ready for the names yeah i find this
[ __ ] so interesting even before i was
trying to name a baby i agree
for boys because it's like you know
it's kind of like how
barbara
you know what i don't even want to
continue my dumb sentences just go yeah
no like the names the top names of today
are going to be like dated like right
like we're going to have like a million
whatever the equivalent of like the
barber was because i'm sure 50 years ago
we were sitting here on our podcast like
barbara top baby if you like when i was
looking for baby names i looked at top
baby names for every decade of the last
100 years and like yeah the 70s they're
all susan right right
diane baby boy names but for boys by the
way it does feel like there's less
trends for boys there are some names
here but like there are i feel like the
boys names and especially a boy versus a
girl bob and will yeah like william is
probably top then top now it is top now
it is
number one liam
that's so trendy it's a little trendy
but it is beautiful number two noah you
love biblical biblical yeah biblical is
forever i love the name noah it's just
everyone's name in their kid noah right
now i know and then your kid will have
like five other noah's in the class
that's like how ben was like one of like
55 bends in his class yeah but it's
still top ten three oliver
so cute sweet i guess it could be trendy
but like i don't know the broadway play
that's like an old player oliver twist
he's a classic guy that's what he meant
four elijah biblical mm-hmm five james
i like james yeah it's not going
anywhere six william not going gorgeous
seven benjamin not going anywhere eight
lucas
biblical new testament
oh interesting i think i don't know by
the way i have no clue if that's true or
not but like i'm always seeing people's
instagram bios like lucas27.5 be kind to
others that's she's a christian queen
[Laughter]
nine that was not me mocking
christianity it was a joke nine henry
love that we were going like maybe henry
or harry yeah like henry like it would
probably be my number one was harry
number two was wolf number three was
henry
love the name henry like so much thank
god i didn't name my kid wolf and then
she changed it no totally what do you
think she's naming we still don't know
and honestly like i'm at the point now
where i truly don't care i love this
journey for her kylie take all the time
that you need it's so important when you
name a child and we're in no rush maybe
william
maybe william or maybe theodore
i would i would simply pass away
theodore's such a gorgeous name
it's like you know it plagues me that i
gave theo my dog the name theo because
he's such a theo don't get me wrong and
he's such a blessing but it's such a
gorgeous human human name
yeah
but he's here they're like
is it so weird to have a dog and a son
named theo no i
personally would vote for it i think
it's so cute totally okay are you ready
for our top baby names for girls more
interesting yes number one olivia
she's been on the top of that list i
[ __ ] hate olivia i'm so jealous of
her name like she is like you say this
all the time and it's so true i've never
met an olivia who isn't just like
absolutely everything of the sort top of
her field top of her class beautiful
like olivia's such a good name and i
feel like in movies and books whenever
there's a character named olivia it's
like she's the best one yeah and it's
also shakespearean so it's really not
going anywhere it's a gorgeous name and
i'm happy for my sister olivia obviously
but you know slightly jealous i don't
love my name
you're such a claudia i what does that
even mean i like your name i think your
name is like unique but also
classic i don't know it just doesn't
feel like me first of all i'm not latin
and like everyone thinks i'm latin oh
interesting um which i'm not so it's
just it's not like an accurate
reflection of my culture
and like i don't know i guess because
there's really not a lot of famous
claudias
except for ray um which i guess is good
i guess it's good like you know on
famousbirthdays.com i'm probably like
the third most famous claudia which is
like being you know like
this
smartest person at harvard like it's
like a relevant but you know like it
counts yeah
no not the smartest person yeah i know i
know
i don't know
um i like your name now when i think
about it like too in depth now i'm i'm
like questioning things like ben never
calls me claudia i'm like if he ever did
i would literally look over my shoulder
like what does he call you who are you
talking to claude moof
oh
big mama
moof [ __ ] get out of the way get out
the way [ __ ]
what does he call me crunch
wait let me think hold on
he does when he's trying to get my
attention he calls me claude okay which
is just like i feel weird like that's
not me um
what do you call him
pops
like if you're like needing a diet coke
pups got it give me lacroix i think my
toxic trait is that my husband babe it's
so
i honestly when i'm around you guys and
you're calling each other babe i'm like
guess is he wrong
yes well so i probably uttered the word
babe a hundred times a day but now and i
feel like i'm always hollering baby and
then i hear myself and then i'll switch
to zack zack sack and now i'm calling
him zack moore because babe isn't
getting his attention hate babe i'm like
in books when it's like hey babe i like
cringed to death i just want you guys to
know i never say hey babe no it's like
get a room like babe can you just grab
that you don't say hey baby baby give me
a trash bag yeah no it's really weird
and not
congruent with who i am not you at all
it's not me at all i think zack started
calling you babe first so you but
there's also something extremely cool
about it like if you can pull it off
like i could just see you know like
austin butler calling kayaker hey babe
you want to go get a green juice yeah
you know no it's very uh but i've become
much more aware of it and it's starting
to change but for the last six years i
have been calling him yeah you have yeah
okay ready for number two girl name oh
yeah used to be number one emma i didn't
know it was so popular pretty name i
think i actually remember a couple years
ago i was talking about this story and
emma being number one
and i honestly really believe it had to
do with the fact that ross and rachel
name their baby emma because it was like
that show was like such a big like
influence on that 90s generation yeah so
i really i know that sounds crazy but i
do believe it no i believe it too things
like that can really influence names
like the female miley arya is becoming
really popular and when hannah montana
was on the name miley became like so
much more it's really crazy yeah because
it's like not a name yeah it's like it's
only her name right number three
charlotte gorgeous oh my god i wish
like i could never have been named
charlotte you're getting me out of
charlotte so sad because i'm not elegant
but like i would have loved to have been
charlotte you would have loved to have
been elegant right
for amelia
cute five ava
i love the name amy that's my mother
name my mother-in-law's name it's a
gorgeous name it's a gorgeous it's also
a pelandrum what's that thing called
yeah palindrome oh
palindrome number six sophia not with an
f but still good
i love that name is fofia on there no
maybe she's further down or maybe they
just put them all together yeah number
seven isabella gorgeous love ate mia
mia ham yeah nine evelyn your girly from
the liquor store
evie also hugo
um cute 10 harper
that's trendy yeah very interesting
there's not a lot of biblical girl names
on there no because i do think that
parents get trendier with girls and more
traditional with boys yeah which is just
like
stereotypical gender roles reinforcing
themselves you hate to see it
do you i don't know like the
even when i was thinking of names
actually i'm traditional all the way but
i would definitely if i was ever going
to go funky it would be fur girl
yeah like sandrine like sandrine yeah
honestly i make so many jokes about
sandrine i might name my daughter at one
day who is she again she's from friends
they're going back and forth it's
actually you okay i know you hate
friends but i hate the show friends but
i like the premises of the episode so
ross and rachel are having a baby and
they're like not together they just
slept together one night spoiler alert
and they're having a baby and they're
like doing it together but like they
like hate each other because they're
like not a couple so they're going back
and forth on names ross is very like
he wants to name his kid darwin like
really like manly they don't know what
they're having yet and rachel is like
sandrine
reign
and so the whole episode is i'm going
back and forth and they end up really um
liking the name ruth
so when ross had a baby first season
he really wanted the name um
okay it's so funny he really you know
his name is ross keller yeah and he
wanted the name helen
got it helen geller yeah and then he
wanted ruth and rachel was like oh
that's disgusting and then she really
came around and like after the whole
episode they're like okay we're going to
go with ruth we're going to have
ourselves a little baby ruth
keep the candy yeah and then they
decided not to do it you have to watch
it you have to watch it okay such a good
episode such a good episode sure sure oh
and then like phoebe's trying to help
them mediate and they keep like so
phoebe's like i'm going to give you guys
three vetoes so you go back and forth
and you have to veto but you only have
so many vetoes and they go back and
forth so many times veto veto veto and
then phoebe's like is the name vito
starting to sound really good to anyone
else it's such a good episode okay yeah
you should watch it i won't oh god
you're so stubborn no no i tried friends
it's not for me it's not for everyone
and i think we just need to let sleeping
dogs lie
okay
what's next
um should we do real houses in new
jersey yeah i think dear toasters for
anyone who doesn't watch housewives you
know oh you are like beyond considerate
dear toasters is brought to you by
billion dollar beauty traditional makeup
palettes are typically filled with
shades that we love shades that we don't
love and we've all been guilty of buying
an entire new palette swearing that
we'll use every color only to use the
same shades because we are all creatures
of habit but that's why billion dollar
beauty was invented all those half-used
makeup palettes and products are
expensive and they add to the growing
amount of waste produced by the beauty
industry billion dollar beauty believes
you should have the option to purchase
just the shade and the products that you
actually use without sacrificing quality
or convenience and that's why the ceo
and founder designed the completely
customizable compact billion dollar
beauty box as a sustainable solution to
expensive excessively packaged makeup
palettes the billion dollar beauty
box is a portable makeup kit that uses
its spill proof magnetic lining and
kickstand mirror lid to secure a full
line of professional quality cruelty
free cosmetics plus all the products for
your box come in minimal recycled
packaging and they are paraben free
vegan and they are leaping bunny
certified cruelty free there are over 40
beauty pans and products to add to your
billion dollar box like the number one
bestselling universal brow pencil the
magnetic brush trio and their eyeshadows
which are some of my favorite i'm
definitely like i use three shades like
a shiny gold and like a caramel brown
and so to buy these huge pellets is so
wasteful money wise and also for the
environment so just being able to choose
exactly which pans you need more of is
so smart um
you may have seen their uh products in
clean beauty sections of target they're
also been in vogue allure glamour um so
join the refill revolution and build
your own billion dollar box at
billiondollarbeauty.com
and receive 20 off your entire purchase
when you enter the code toast at
checkout that's billion dollar
beauty.com
billiondollarbeauty.com 20 off when you
use code toast all right dear toasters
our weekly advice segment every
wednesday where you write in and we do
our absolute best to help you if you
ever want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com and it is always done
anonymously so let's go hey girls my
husband's best friend is dating this
girl they've been together for about
four years and she's absolutely
miserable to be around she complains
whines [ __ ] argues curses with her
boyfriend about everything and anything
she does it in front of everyone and
they are constantly fighting they'll get
in huge fights in front of all of us and
then she'll pout and make awful little
comments to him for the rest
of the night this happens about 90
97 of the time that we are around them
honestly we haven't said anything to the
boyfriend because we kind of assumed
that he would end it on his own terms
because we get tired of it however he
just bought a ring and is about to
propose and we think that he's making
the worst decision of his life we have a
pretty big friend group and we've opened
up to mostly everyone about how we feel
and they each 100 agree with with us
they can't stand her what do we do let
him make potentially the worst mistake
of his life by marrying her or say
something to him and hopefully save him
a lot of years of heartbreak p.s he's
literally the best guy ever and we just
think he deserves 100 better thanks
well it's not like you're telling him
something that he doesn't know or like
can't see with his own two eyes it's
just your personal opinion
and i don't think it's going to change
anything except honestly hurt your
friendship with him yeah like i know i
know what you see is bad but you really
never know like what a real relationship
is like behind closed doors no but it's
like he what you see he sees that every
that she's miserable around you guys i'm
sure if she's even more miserable to be
around one-on-one and he's still making
this decision like maybe you could have
your husband talk to him and be like
you sure yeah you sure like you want to
talk it out how does she make you feel
but it's not like you're telling him
that you know that she does all these
terrible things cheats on you like blah
blah blah right that he doesn't know so
and some guys like like [ __ ] women
like maybe that's just as tight yeah and
people have to live their own lives and
make their own decisions maybe he
reminds she reminds him of his mother
and also it's like maybe if you know if
you're someone's sibling or a parent
yeah you said listen i do not like this
person that you've chosen i would like
to let you know that before you make
this big life decision it's your
decision to make but i just think you
should know that you know the family
doesn't like her it's different if a
friend comes to you and says i don't
like your girlfriend i say [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off goodbye like i agree like
unfortunately i do think like your reign
ends here like you don't really have any
luck to stand and it's not this like
obligation i know you feel obligated but
it's just your opinion yeah and it's not
like he doesn't seem happy and it's not
like he doesn't know like the things you
don't like about her it's not she does
behind his back she's doing it in the
middle of the room right you could maybe
say if this is true like the
friend your husband could say to him
like
bro you don't seem happy are you sure
that you know just just trying to
understand how he feels more but you
know he's not going to call off his
engagement because you guys don't like
her nor really should he i agree sadly
i'm sorry that you're not going to have
to like hang out with this girl yeah
because there's and i realize how beyond
hypocritical it is of me to say this
because i'm i don't think anybody on the
planet complains more than me i think
the worst trait in a person is like when
they are non-stop complaining i do feel
like it's okay when i do it because i'm
hysterical and like i always make it
into a joke yes but like if people are
like oh i'm hot oh it's ugly in here
like shut up that's like my like
literally i want to smack that like shut
up but when i do it it's like oh it is
hotter than which is coochie in here you
know i'm like hilarious yeah i agree
with all of those things thanks um but
it's literally the most annoying quality
yeah just like debbie downer like that's
skit on snl yes like it's just like
naggy and it's we can't even have fun
because you're pointing out like yeah we
know it's hot but like yeah move on yeah
um best of luck i do suggest keeping you
around you know so like life changes and
even though you probably see them all
the time now like in five years and when
like they get married and you guys have
kids like
things change and you probably will see
less of her so this is just a phase at a
stage of your life yeah and if she's not
someone who sparks joy you won't be
seeing her all the time you do sound
like a nosy queen which i definitely
relate to and i do think like you you
would be overstepping
you for sure your husband maybe can just
really do that like hey bro are you
happy she complains a lot it's just like
you could do that but like he'd be like
what's going on like boys don't sit down
and be like bro
talk to me about your interior life yeah
like what he would be like are you dying
um best of luck
all right next up hey girls og breath
are here the only part i love about my
hour commute is getting to listen to the
toast so when i had the most horrendous
thing happen to me i knew it was the
time to submit i'm getting married next
july and i have two childhood best
friends tigs and rice
when i was making my wedding website i
was originally planning to have tigs as
my maid of honor and bryce as my matron
of honor but i later decided only to
have tiggs as my maid of honor oh
bright's got shafted fast forward a few
months bryce offered to help me with
some of the wording on my wedding
website i obliged and sent her the link
and much to my dismay i got a text from
her exclaiming how excited she was to be
my matron of honor i was completely
shook and so confused until i looked at
the website and right there under her
name it said matron of honor and all
[ __ ] caps i was shook to my core i
literally have been ignoring her and i
have no idea what to do do i just let
her be mature matron of honor even
though i don't want her to or do i tell
her the truth and have her forever know
she didn't make the cut sincerely i
should have double checked my work
toaster
i think you're stuck i think you're
stuck too because like what's the big
deal why did you want her to be matron
of honor and now you don't it's just
like you don't want a matron of honor
like it might just be easier but at
least she was in the running it's not
like you accidentally put like your
third cousin's name and also like
what
does a matron of honor even do it's just
like a figurehead title like let bryce
think honestly
i think it's like a disrespectful title
it's like you're my friend but old no
it's the married maid of honor you could
have too i believe because if you're a
matron you're married but i feel like
some people make i guess and then also
it's like okay so one more person who's
taking up the mantle for a lot of your
wedding things like and she's obviously
really like you know pumped about it no
and she's um very hands-on she asks can
i help you what's tiggs doing by the way
right that's working on your website
that's exactly just bryce get chapped
huh no because the thing is when you're
as beautiful stunning and smart as kids
like of course these things just happen
to you and i totally i totally get the
position you're in but this is for bryce
in all seriousness she's a good friend
bryce sounds like a good time gal and a
gal who's willing to like get her hands
dirty and help and that's the exactly
type of [ __ ] you need in your wedding
party yeah so this might have been a
blessing in disguise let bryce be your
matron of honor because you know what
it'll mean so much to her and it really
doesn't it's no sweat off your back and
in a few years you won't even remember
these semantics like it doesn't matter
and it's not worth having a painful
conversation with a very excited bryce
no totally bryce deserves better christ
deserves better i think you just leave
it 100 leave it leave it leave it
alright ready for our third and final
yeah hi jackie claudia jackie welcome
back full time thank you for all your
mom content i love it so here's my
situation at a baby last july i bought a
decent amount of maternity clothing
because i work in person about a month
or so after i delivered i had a friend
of a friend a girl i had been decently
friends with reached out and asked to
borrow some of my maternity clothes to
get her through the end of her pregnancy
i happily agreed to let her borrow some
clothes as this was my first baby i
wanted the clothes back and many were
the high-end pieces like lululemon or
many of them were high-end pieces or
lululemon clothing that i sized up in
fast forward to now her baby is seven
months old and i'm and my best friend is
pregnant i really
want to share my clothes with my best
friend and also want my freaking clothes
back i sent this girl a text message and
i've heard nothing back she sometimes
sucks at texting back so how long do i
wait to message her again how do i get
my clothes back also now i'm nervous and
she borrowed some baby stuff for me like
an extra boppy is it all lost too i've
been more than generous during her
pregnancy and after bringing gifts and
meals with little to no things and i'm
so frustrated do i involve this the girl
who introduced us i look back on our
text messages i said borrow multiple
times save me from this mama drama i
will totally share updates that's tough
that's tough get your [ __ ] back you said
borrow also
how magnanimous like too
unnecessarily to lend all this stuff to
a friend of a friend like
she's taking advantage of your kindness
and it's not not to get your [ __ ] back
get your [ __ ] back it's very possible
that like she misunderstood and thought
like you were just giving it to her
because you just had the baby like why
do you need maternity clothes and like
maybe gifted it to someone else or like
donated it which might be why she's not
responding okay well then you need to
find that out but she can't just leave
you on red that's poor manners and yeah
maybe get your mutual friend involved to
get to the bottom of it because and you
know what maybe just call her what if
you just called her up because text
messaging you know as a mom i'm sure
like you're [ __ ] busy so so many
times i get a text message i'm like oh
yes clocking it need to respond and then
don't have the band
no and also even before i was a mom like
sometimes i just get a text message that
i forget that i got yeah and then it's
when like
three weeks later i'm like oh you
responded so definitely follow up call
her get your friend involved because you
need to get your stuff back that's not
nice i agree 100
and like
just
stop being so nice yeah agreed like
that's like one like i would lend
anything to my best friend but to lend
like an entire wardrobe to a friend of a
friend is not necessarily yeah maybe
this is a lesson um for life like
there's just no need to be so nice to
everyone no good deed goes on punishment
oh my god ain't that the truth sis um
that was your toasters and if you ever
want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com
let's talk about the real housewives of
new jersey third and final part of the
reunion before our austin interview
um it was so good
yes
okay so i just have to say like ben came
in and watched with me and when he came
on the men were on
and then when he left he's like wait
they're leaving i'm like yeah he's like
why and he was like so upset and then he
wanted to watch 30 rock before bed but
right when housewives ended the house
husbands episode of watch droppings live
was on and i'm like oh do you want to
watch this he's like um i guess
he was cracking up like literally never
saw something so funny in his whole life
it was a really good episode of watch
what happens live it was i only watched
until the first commercial break and
then i went to sleep it was good they
were all like being like kind of quiet
but like still funny i think because one
i think their mics were muted if they
weren't being spoken to directly because
it's a lot of people and you know
it's nice these are just like regular
guys it's so crazy they're just regular
guys they're not like media trained
celebrities yeah they have like regular
jobs and as most of the husbands on real
housewives are but like none other are
as featured as these guys and it's just
i'm obsessed i can't get enough no and
you know what i thought last night's
episode was really good for louis
not only finally like and
i think it registered with him he's a
logical person even though like i i
think he definitely has a weird [ __ ]
up pass he's not illogical like teresa
like he is logical so the fact that a
watch happens live they did a poll are
you looking at louis differently after
the reunion and it was like 80 yes i
think it's really registering with him
like margaret was actually not trying to
hurt him at all and if he had just
gotten that ahead of it and like spoken
about it it wouldn't have been a
storyline the entire season like that's
how this [ __ ] works yeah and i mean
teresa really zeroed in on margaret but
before she did like when i looked back
on like who's bringing up louis stuff
like it didn't feel like it was margaret
you know bringing it up all the time
like all the women were talking about it
like teresa just has it out for margaret
yeah and made this whole thing like
margaret's bringing it up when it was
everybody was talking about it and by
the way the fact that louie lost his job
is really interesting to me i don't know
how you can lose a job at a company that
you own but that was like really sad and
i definitely feel
louie said theresa didn't want me to
tell everyone this and not because she
was being a martyr but because i think
teresa is like so
toxically traditional that like a man
without a job is like in the old italian
like that would never happen
so i found that to be like so beyond
interesting and when andy asked do you
blame margaret he said no for me i was
like you know what louie's not such a
bad guy yeah no he has scents
and maybe if teresa allowed the story
arc to continue over the season where
they asked him questions and he answered
just like he did at the reunion we would
have liked him people would have liked
him and
uh it would have been more favorable and
i'm not saying he wouldn't have lost his
job because also that's like
a little weird to lose your job over
something from a tv show but it's like
it's not from a tv show it's from the
art he said from all the articles like
right so if you're an employee and like
all these articles start coming out
about you that you're abusive
emotionally then it has nothing to do
with the show right it has to do with
you right but
his articles only came out because he's
on the show now yeah yeah teresa is so
delusional she's so painful um i thought
margaret did a good job of like holding
her own to the best of her ability even
andy got like so and you know andy
really did a good job i think he cuddles
teresa a lot but when he literally
turned her was like have you ever
changed your mind about anything like
ever thought to yourself oh i was wrong
about that
i changed my mind and she was like yeah
and jennifer was like yeah i've seen her
do it i was she was like when yeah oh
but a really interesting development
melissa and joe
you know melissa has a podcast and they
did an episode literally dropped
yesterday the day before
they are turnt on teresa like you could
see and andy said i'm watching up inside
like it feels like things are going in a
different direction with you and like
yeah we're on our way like there was
dayton for so many years but like now
the gorga trees uh judaism is flared up
again and i think i mean obviously it
has to do with the fact
i don't know how any human being could
put up with teresa but also like
melissa is so
irrelevant on the show when they were
all going around things they've learned
and she was like and tony is back in
cheer i was like oh my god like get
tracy out here who was totally
comfortable
she was there like she had a whole she
was covered like she was in the cast
photo like she wore a gold dress and her
hair was really long you're lying
and you know what because there was so
much to discuss i feel like they didn't
even really get to harp on teresa's
table flip that much like yeah there was
so much oh my god because i also wanted
to hear from tiki that's why i wanted
tracy to be there because he was one of
the guys who was asking questions and i
just watched the chris stefano special
where he yeah i talked about tiki barber
i was crying so i was really waiting to
hear from tiki and like what he thought
about being part of the housewives he
was literally i do believe i don't know
if he was there but she was fully
photographed on a couch she brought in a
chair for her friend of gone oh my god i
mean it's safe to say she won't be on
next season even though i liked her i
didn't mind her i didn't but i do feel
like the six current cast members like
there's so much more
ground to cover yeah and i know i've
said like i'm so upset jackie got
demoted because man have i turned around
on her um but somebody did offer a
unique insight to me that it's possible
that part of the reason she was
demoted is bravo looking out for her
health
which i can totally understand even
though i just don't see bravo like ever
sacrifice like production companies
don't sacrifice entertainment for
people's mental health it's like not a
thing no and also she said on the show
on the reunion last night like the show
saved her life so like
it could be looked at differently jackie
was mvp of like the whole reunion and
when she drank the whole champagne and
everyone was like wow she's like i'm
eating now so i need to drink it was
she's like look she's doing such a good
job of like handling this and it's still
so interesting you know me i [ __ ]
hate personal story lines like i just
have no time for them i couldn't get
enough of jackie's journey i'm like so
upset we're not going to be seeing her
it's not confirmed that she's demoted
yes it is how where where was it
confirmed everywhere oh [ __ ] it's
confirmed i mean it's possible she gives
a banger season and they actually just
continued to like keep her in but for
now they're treating her as a friend of
while they just started filming that's
so unnecessary like keep the six women
bring in a different friend of like it's
working it's working even tracy like it
was working
yeah and we never say that we're always
like there needs to be a big overhaul
yeah no it's perfection and that's the
thing even with theresa like i want to
[ __ ] shake her
name a [ __ ] who's been on the show
longer and is still literally the most
talked about person like she she is the
show and like i get why she is the way
that she is and
i've i can't even talk about like the
feelings i feel when i watch her and
that's good television even though i
literally hate her yeah no it's good
because what she's really you know
someone that can be a villain for a lot
of people except for like the one
percent of voters who like thought that
teresa had a good reunion yeah
but so not only is she like the villain
of the group but she has close
relationships with
doris and jennifer and ellis is her
sister so it's not like this person
who's constantly on the fridge no it's
so she has to be involved also um
so on melissa and joe's podcast what i
thought was weird is like melissa and
joe have so many legitimate gripes with
teresa i mean they could literally write
a novel and what they chose to say on
the podcast was like
basically that teresa's kids would be
homeless if it weren't for theresa for
melissa and joe um they really held down
the fort on the show when teresa was in
jail which is like really not true um so
it was just like of all the times they
finally decide to speak out against
teresa like that's what they say because
that's like not even something
as like a teresa hater i can really even
like
agree with yeah the show was not good
without teresa and he asked joe about it
on march and he said that like this show
has been amazing because it's centered
around our family drama and without you
know our pieces that's true the show who
knows if theresa would still be a
housewife that's like not what he said
on the podcast i listened to clips like
it was different okay well that's his
explanation on watch robin's live he
made sense so he's saying like
his continued success is because of this
dynamic but the same can be said for the
gor theresa could say the same thing
about them a hundred percent i mean
that's not like why i think they should
be angry with teresa they should be
angry with teresa for treating them like
crap yeah and always taking like her new
friend's side over melissa but melissa
versus theresa and they've started
filming already and this podcast just
came out melissa versus teresa like is
coming it is a thing and you know what
i'm happy for melissa because she was on
a one-way ticket to nowhere being
theresa's friends no but also i think
the issue is like teresa was always
demanding like a level of loyalty from
melissa that she would not give her in
return instead of just being like listen
we'll never go at each other like we
used to but i don't expect from you what
i wouldn't give to you and you're
different and those are your friends
these are my friends who are family
whatever but like she whole every time
margaret says something it's like
melissa yeah well that would require
teresa to be a logical reasonable person
which unfortunately she is not right
it was so good like when andy
that was so funny um it was just really
really good i loved having the men
around they're literally the best part
of the show they're the best part of the
show my boy evan jobenigno i love him
embracing his eye lift we literally did
not say one thing at the reunion or i
watched evan's life or other than his
eye lift but he's like another one i
look at him and i laugh because it's
just like he's your average joe and he's
like on this tv show and it's so funny
who do you think said less on the
reunion joe benigno or alex from
summerhouse
joe benigno
i think alex from summerhouse but at
least alex from summerhouse like he kept
getting in all the previews for the
honda civic of mail attraction right oh
right that was like his big yeah joe
didn't have like a one-liner i know it's
so true um
bill aiden was being really cute on my
travis live and honestly like i feel
like this happens at every reunion where
i have a really like
i watch it sympathetically for jennifer
like she does a good job and jackie was
right like i do feel like she could be
really good friends with all the women
but like her toxic loyal blindness to
theresa is just like always getting in
the way during the seasons but like she
comes off really like i don't know i
feel like they're really deep deep deep
down there is like a good gal there no
there's a side of jennifer that i love i
know i would want to be friends with
there's also a side that just like says
and does things that are beyond not
defensible and you know what but also
like her logic and her
thought processes as she's explaining on
the reunion like i get her yeah you know
what though
as much as i i do believe margaret was
like extremely sympathetic and didn't
really think like it would blow up in
the way that it did for bringing up the
affair and i do believe she was genuine
in a way i'm still really glad that she
did because i think like she kept
drilling on like i wasn't saying it to
hurt you i was saying it to point out
the fact that you are in a glass house
and you throw stones at the end of the
day i do believe jennifer received that
message she was like i'm gonna try to
move forward like not be such like a a
nasty [ __ ] yeah and so
if all of that
if we get that from all of this i will
be happy no and i need jennifer and
margaret to still be cool because that
was one of my favorite scenes of the
entire season like when they saw each
other like
margaret saw that jennifer was hurting
and jennifer saw that margaret wasn't
trying to hurt her and like margaret
gets this rap for being just like this
villainous queen bone carrying queen and
she's really not like she is
a good friend yeah
yeah that the right side of the couch
is like the obvious
it's logical and it's like real
friendship for the versus the left side
it's like old italian friendship which
means oh you can't ask teresa a question
yeah what did andy say oh yeah like
delores knew about the rumors but never
asked them yeah and andy was like yeah
because she's italian
yeah
and then theresa said something like if
she had asked i would tell her no she
said well she knew not to ask because
she knows i would never be with someone
who was physically abusive yeah the
delusion the thinking i just can't
follow it no me neither so it was like
an amazing like really amazing season of
jersey and it's been it's always an
amazing season it is that show it is i'm
gonna miss it i am too i'm really gonna
miss the husbands like they're so i'm
cute so obsessed with the husbands like
every single one no there's not a bad
husband no if there were to be a bad
husband
there's not one
no there's not
who's sitting next to joe
gorga yeah evan no he was in the back
who's in the middle i'm like blinking it
was joe gorga someone frank catania no
they were all behind their women oh i'm
talking about the reunions yeah i'm
talking about them which happens
no so in the back was joe benigno evan
and billy i knew he was in the middle oh
exactly
um yeah but he was growing up and also
he's not a husband yet like yeah i don't
think of him as part of the crew yet
it's still early days yeah i wonder so
teresa's wedding is soon
i wonder if it's going to be on the show
margaret obviously is not invited but
like honestly i feel like melissa might
not be like after this podcast yeah like
that i'm looking forward to watching
yeah wow we're going back so far no i
know but it has to be done
and also after watching ultimate girls
trip it's like these two do not like
each other they can't agree on anything
and like it's all it was a ceasefire but
it was never meant to last no it was not
mental it's such a good way of putting
it um so we will miss new jersey but um
yeah that means potomac is coming back
soon which is so exciting so exciting
beverly hills is back
dubai june bye i'm southern
so that was our tv recap and that is our
show if you're listening as a podcast
stay tuned for our interview with austin
kroll and please be open-minded reminder
he's not a murderer and if you want to
catch it on youtube head over to our
youtube channel and [ __ ]
subscribe
subscribe
and that's our show thank you so much
for listening to the morning shows of
the millennium morning show where we
deliver the first live stream each and
every monday friday and youtube super
watching youtube please please subscribe
give this video a thumbs up rules
available podcast editor podcast we
found some spotify just your public
video i already boxed all the way babies
and buttons somebody just loves
everybody beautiful that's where we are
have an amazing day you guys will see
you tomorrow bye
you